but first we turn to the weak cognitive
mess
that is sippy cup joe who definitely
missed nap time today because
he seemed to be extremely fussy and
quite irritable
during prepared remarks at the white
house he randomly
out of nowhere started yelling in what
was a bizarre
strange outburst you decide
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
every time we're silent
every time we let hate flourish
we make a lie of who we are as a nation
i mean it literally
we cannot let the very foundation
of this country continue to be eaten
away
like it has been in other moments in our
history and happening again
was joe biden like this in 2016 2012
because well joe let's be honest never
particularly a smart or a bright guy
but what we're now seeing sadly for him
is a hollow shell of his former self a
total
complete cognitive mess what's really
sad is the reality
that if we can all see it so can
america's
enemies and we have real enemies in iran
in china north korea
russia vladimir putin doesn't respect or
fear joe biden in fact
none of these people do none of these
countries do he just steamrolled
vladimir did biden who rubber stamp
rushes get this
new pipeline project into western europe
into germany
remember biden just killed our pipeline
the keystone xl pipeline the one that
was paying
thousands of of hard-working americans
high-paying
career jobs and artificially limiting
america's supply of oil and gas
creating energy dependence and higher
prices
not only at the pump but for heating and
cooling your home
and everything you buy in every store
that gets there by
a truck that is fueled by diesel now we
were all told that this was being done
in the name of the environment
ending the keystone xl pipeline but
according to joe it was worth it
because he was saving the earth and
climate change listening
to the radical squad in congress and
bernie sanders
well apparently that was a massive lie
because if it was about the environment
why did he just lift sanctions on
the russian nordstream pipeline give a
special exemption
so his flynn friend vladimir can get
rich
again it makes russia rich again it
makes our western european allies
dependent
on vladimir putin hostile actor russia
hostile regime
now our friendly countries now count on
him
for the lifeblood of their economies
that's not good
and this is what american last policies
look like
this was putting putin first and russia
first
last week russians hacked america's
largest pipeline system
causing massive fuel shortages in 17
states
all along the east coast up and down the
east coast
and this week they were rewarded with
their very own pipeline into germany
and you know well screw american jobs
all those guys that had career jobs on
the pipeline
in the energy sector you know screw
american energy independence
we're all going to pay higher prices and
every american
you know there's wealth and prosperity
and safety and security
by not needing foreign sources of energy
now we're energy dependent again
and sure go ahead vladimir you do
whatever you want or senator tom cotton
put it
vladimir putin is going to achieve his
top foreign policy objective
thanks to president biden biden called
president trump putin's puppy
well what does that make joe biden
putin's puppy dog suck up
why did hillary even send uranium which
we don't have enough supply of
to russia then the money got kicked back
to the clinton foundation
tell vladimir on more more flexibility
after the election obama
don't worry biden's willfully ignorant
press secretary doesn't understand
why anybody could possibly be upset
about
american pipelines shut down jobs lost
higher energy prices and putin
he gets a waiver he gets to build it
take a look
i know that there's a lot of talk about
nordstrom and keystone and i'm just
trying to
help our help people understand it is
there
well yes so how is he urging other
countries to take ambitious climate
action
if he's letting other countries build
north stream too first we're hardly
letting
any country or other countries build
nordstrom 2. when the president took
office
95 of this pipeline was built
it seemed like there was the ability by
the us government to
sanction some officials to stop the
project at like 95
but you're not doing it and
understanding in what way were we
we're going to be able to stop a project
in another country that's had been
or maybe built 95 maybe more difficult
with the sanctions on some of these
officials involved
madam circle back listen to me this is
not complicated
joe gave putin and russia a waiver
he signed off on it joe was trying to
appease the climate socialist in his
radical base
while also appeasing america's enemies
abroad
never forget democrats put politics
above all out else
and don't take my word for it just
listen to vice president
harris who sees covet this is an
opportunity
colvin's an opportunity for what an
opportunity to transform
america and elections take a look
as we emerge from the pandemic i believe
that we are at the start of a new era
i believe that we have a unique
opportunity now
to shape our nation's future to
transform
how we live how we work and how we vote
for the better radically transformed
what
into the great socialist utopia that
will always end in broken promises
more poverty and a loss of freedom
because that's the result more reliance
on big government
more entitlements you get to keep your
doctor planned and
save money that didn't work out and then
of course let's get rid of
all voter id you need voter id to get
oh a jewel pod for example you need
voter id to buy a six pack of beer you
need voter id
to get into the democratic national
convention the white house or the
capitol
and you need voter id for pretty much
everything but we'll get rid of that for
voting
we'll get rid of any type of signature
verification
and democrats can then rig this system
harvest votes win elections in
perpetuity
and turn this country into a socialist
climate-obsessed hell hole
never let a crisis go to waste right
kamala now of course democrats they'll
need all the political help they can get
in 2022 and 2024.
the biden administration has been
nothing short of a train wreck or as the
wall street journal put it
did biden peak on inauguration day
covet confusion mideast chaos the threat
of inflation
and he doesn't have many victories to
point to
except donald trump's vaccine so
speaking of covert confusion get this
nancy pelosi is mandating
everyone in the house of representatives
wear a mask
because she doesn't want the halls of
congress to turn into a quote
petri dish anyone caught without a mask
gets slapped with a 500
fine first offense 2500 fine for any
offense thereafter
and according to the cdc it's safe for
vaccinated americans to stop wearing
masks
inside and outside as a matter of fact
look at your screen
nancy pelosi let's see rafael warnock
many others
they were packed in a room at the white
house today
without a mask in sight so it seems like
sometimes democrats trust the experts
when it's convenient
they trust the science when convenient
and sometimes they don't
when they can think they can bludgeon a
republican sometimes they believe in
vaccines
sometimes they don't beyond bizarre you
want me to give you an explanation
i can't possibly i don't think the
smartest shrink in the world could do
to could be capable of diagnosing that
insanity
now especially because these are the
same people who demanded
we follow the science and trust the
experts
and always listen to the doctors at the
cdc you know the ones that took
dictation from the teachers union
the same teachers union that gives money
to elect democrats remember this
and it's critical critical critical
critical
that they follow the science we have
followed the science and what i've
insisted on from day one
is that we have to follow the science
you know my faith has no quarrel with
science we've got to be patient
we have to exercise sound judgment and
follow the science
everything else we're talking about is
will just continue
and perhaps worsen unless we crush the
virus so
follow the science we want to follow uh
medical expertise
and science over political
considerations
i think joe biden has said that over and
over and i agree with him
that should be the standard all right
nancy why don't you trust the cdc
and why aren't you following the science
for example why don't you trust the
experts
now tonight i urge every member of
congress to personally sue
the speaker speaker pelosi over this
anti-science mask mandate and do what
congressman thomas massey did
and file pelosi's mask warnings in the
trash can
where they belong but it's not just
pelosi
failed governor gavin newsom up for
recall about to bribe two-thirds of
californians with a check
he's demanding if you live in california
you wear a mask for at least another
month
but get the science there too texas they
ditched all coveted mandates months ago
remember kids in florida have been back
in person learning since
august and by the way texas recorded
zero cover deaths for the first time
now what's wrong with newsom is he
really that stupid
or does he think the money that he's
going to give to two-thirds of
californians
are going to get checks he has a 75
billion dollar surplus
just got 40 plus billion from the
federal government with the blue state
bailout
you know red state americans their money
is going to go to two-thirds of
californians
including i'm told the illegal
immigrants just like illegal immigrants
in new york and new jersey got checks
now thanks to operation warp speed
thanks to president trump
vaccines therapeutics they are readily
available and by the way
free of charge to any american that
wants one
this is a modern day miracle that is
crushing culvert 19.
but if you want to keep wearing a mask
for whatever reason that is your
business
not mine i will urge you to please
protect people around you
that might not have been vaccinated that
would be vulnerable to getting really
sick
now but don't you dare force others
and tell them what they should do
medically that's between them and their
doctor
especially if you're an elected official
who swore an oath to support
and defend the constitution of the
united states hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else